alors effectivement je vais vous parler
d'un sujet qui est à la croisée des
chemins entre les chemins entre
différentes disciplines qu'elle soit
scientifique soit industriel qu'elle
soit commerciale ce sujet c'est la
fabrication est dit yves alors la
fabrication additive vous en avez
sûrement déjà entendu parler sous un nom
un peu plus générique qui est impression
3d puisque dans la grande famille des
technologies de fabrication additive on
en trouve une qui ait l'impression 3d et
qui est destiné au grand public
vous en avez donc certainement entendu
parler sous cet aspect là et je ne vais
pas vous parler de cette technologie là
je vais vous parler de technologies qui
sont plus destinés à l'industrie et des
opportunités qu'elle ouvre en termes de
conception et de réflexion et de
synergie entre différentes disciplines
scientifiques alors dans un premier
temps je vais vous présenter un petit
peu principe de fonctionnement de cette
technologie là alors j'ai choisi de vous
présenter une technologie ou une famille
de technologie qui est basée sur la
fusion laser de l'ide poudres
métalliques
alors ce diagramme est un petit peu
austère mais je vous ai prévu une vidéo
après qui devrait vous mettre les idées
un peu plus en place donc pour faire
simple comme dans toutes les méthodes de
production on démarre toujours d'une
pièce 3d qu'on a modelé sur un pc à
l'aide de l'outil informatique
cette pièce est ensuite découpé par un
logiciel en tranches successives suivant
un certain axe qui sera l'ex de
fabrication et ce à partir de là que la
fabrication démarre réellement et la
fabrication consiste en ce que la
machine récupère chacune de ces tranches
et les interprètent comme une couche de
fabrication donc on va venir déposer un
lead poudres métalliques sur un plateau
de fabrication excusez moi et ensuite on
va venir tirer sur celui de poudre dans
les zones indiquées de matière pour y
construire la pièce couche par couche et
on va libérer comme ceux ci est ensuite
on ressort la pièce un petit peu comme
un paléontologue où on a le gâteau de
poudre et la pièce prises à l'intérieur
et avec une petite brosse on vient faire
apparaître la pièce j'avais prévu une
petite vidéo
d'une machine en fonctionnement sur une
couche de poudre donc vous voyez les
quatre laser c'est une machine un peu
spécial qui possède quatre laser
simultanée et la vidéo a été fournie
gracieusement par une société française
basée à salon de provence qui s'appelle
polish équipe vous voyez au niveau du
laser on en a les quatre tirs simultanés
qui viennent fusionner la poule 1 donc
là dessus vous avez donc des
propriétaires un petit peu particulière
qui vont se placer au niveau des
matériaux c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui est visuellement c'est
très parlant c'est très moi je suis pas
dit j'ai passé des heures et des heures
devant ces machines à regarder ce genre
de choses
donc voilà pour une couche de poudre de
lait ce qui se passe et vous construisez
itération après itération couche après
couche votre pièce donc ça laisse bien
sûr un certain ça laisse rêveur sur les
opportunités en termes de fabrication et
l'industrie l'a bien compris puisque
comme vous le constater on fabrique en
2d et non plus en 3d on fabrique par
addition de matière et non plus par
soustraction de matière comme on le
faisait avec l'usinage par exemple et on
fabrique avec un outil qui est
inexistant puisque c'est un laser alors
les domaines d'application très vite ça
s'est répandue parce qu'il ya tout un
tas de technologies et notamment les
technologies ouvertes au grand public et
ça s'est répandu à tous les domaines de
l'industrie
mais très vite aussi l'industrie à
chercher à trouver quels étaient les
vrais avantages en termes économiques en
termes industriels en termes de
conception pour elle même parmi ces
avantages je vais vous en présenter un
aujourd'hui que je vais développer et
qu'il s'agit de la capacité à générer
des formes très complexe notamment
alvéolaire puisque canton je prends
l'exemple de l'usinage pour vous
illustrer ça quand vous venez usine est
un produit vous partez dans l'eau peint
de matière qui est de dimensions
supérieures à la pièce finale et vous
venez avec un outil enlevé de la matière
se posera la question de l'accessibilité
de la matière avec mon outil est ce que
je peux avoir accès à toutes les zones
eh bien les industriels où vous
répondront que non et c'est une
contrainte principale dans les processus
de conception avec les méthodes de
fabrication additive vous n'avez plus
d'outils donc plus d'interactions outils
matière et vous travaillez dans des
plantes de des successifs donc vous
gagner énormément en
capacité de forme en capacité de
conception en témoignent les pièces que
vous avez derrière moi et qui ont des
formes complètement très complexe et qui
serait impossible d'atteindre avec des
technologies classiques type usinage
enfin c'est une slide qui est peut-être
un petit peu austère je vais passer
rapidement ne vous en faites pas les
méthodes classiques
qui dit nouvelle technologie de
fabrication d'une nouvelle méthode de
conception les méthodes classiques qui
était basée sur les procédés d'usinage
avait pour objet la paramétrer c'est à
dire qu'on venait définir un certain
nombre de paramètres sur une structure
et on faisait évoluer ces paramètres en
fonction des contraintes dans lesquels
elle évoluer en fonction de la de
l'insertion de la pièce dans un système
plus grands et des contraintes
mécaniques thermiques et tout type de
contraintes qu'il pouvait s'appliquer à
cette pièce et cette méthode consistait
à faire varier ses paramètres en
fonction des contraintes et en fait ça
tombait très bien puisque c'est
exactement ce que fait la fabrication
derrière quand vous venez modifier une
épaisseur par le calcul ou un diamètre
par le calcul et que vous venez l'usiné
votre pièce derrière ce que fait l'outil
c'est qu'il vient modifier ce diamètre
ou cette épaisseur également ça c'était
intéressant pour l'usinage maintenant
qu'on a accès à des formes plus
complexes se pose la question est-ce que
c'est toujours valable est ce que c'est
toujours pertinents il n'en s'aperçoit
que non notamment pour pouvoir exploiter
ses formes complexes dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure et il ya une
méthode mathématique qui a été
développée au début du 20e siècle et
dont l'auteur principal le père
fondateur si je puis dire et henri
poincaré un français et un des derniers
scientifique complet de son époque
cet homme-là donc à développer la
topologie et la topologie a pour objet
les déformations continue alors vous ai
mis un ballon de plage qui captent votre
attention j'en suis sûre depuis que ses
slides et afficher le principe de la
topologie aidés des formations continues
c'est exactement ce qui se passe avec se
veulent dire que lorsque vous partez
d'un ballon plat et que vous venez le
gonfler sa topologie et conserver si
maintenant comme vous le voyez en
dessous vous venez rompre une notion de
voisinage ou vous n'êtes percer une
surface vous rompez la topologie ce que
l'on faisait quand on modifier des
paramètres on conservait la topologie
et on était bloqué dans une topologie
aujourd'hui avec ces méthodes la
topologie peut changer on peut accéder à
des formes beaucoup plus complexe alors
je vous présente un homme
grégory perelman qui est un russe un
petit peu particulier pour le moins
puisque poincaré avec conjectures et une
certaine propriété qui est exactement
celle que vous voyez avec le wallon qui
disait que pour une certaine famille
d'objets en les déformant continûment on
retombe et toujours sur une sphère ce
problème là en 1923 et je me souviens
bien des scientifiques se sont réunis
pour définir les plus grands problèmes
mathématiques du siècle et même du
millénaire ce problème là était le
problème du millénaire quelques à peine
cent ans après une crise gorille
perelman démontre cette propriété et
l'année d'après démontré une propriété
encore plus fondamentale et pour
l'anecdote cet homme l'un du fait de
cette démonstration s'est vu proposé en
2006 la médaille fields qui est
l'équivalent du prix nobel en
mathématiques et ainsi qu'une prime de 1
million de dollars par un institut
américain qui avait proposé cette somme
pour accélérer les recherches et grigori
perelman des a refusé tous les deux je
voulais se tirer votre morale de cette
histoire alors la topologie ça peut être
très compliqué si on y rentre vraiment
en termes de mathématiques mais ça peut
être très amusant si on le regarde d'un
point de vue un peu plus ludiques comme
sur ces vidéos vous avez deux structures
qui soumise à des contraintes évoluent
au fur et à mesure des itérations et on
obtient des formes qui sont à la fois
très complexe mais surtout qui rappelle
quelque chose derrière qui rappellent
des formes organiques
on se rapproche de structures qui
ressemble à de l'osce et la comparaison
bien sûr continue puisque le l'intérêt
principal de l'industrie et c'est ce
dont je vais vous parler en tout cas du
secteur industriel dont je vais vous
parler c'est la réduction des masses
lorsque vous envoyer un satellite dans
l'espace pour fixer les idées alors ça
dépend bien entendu des missions des
lanceurs mais pour fixer les idées un
kilogramme de matière c'est environ 150
mille dollars pour l'expédier dans
l'espace cette industrie là à une
recherche très forte en allègement des
structures
et quand on observe la nature qui est
quand même le premier système
d'optimisation que l'on est sous les
yeux le plus puissant le plus performant
le plus long on observe que chez les
grands animaux c'est pour ça que je vous
ai présenté un squelette de dinosaure la
masse était prépondérante sont des
animaux qui font plusieurs dizaines de
mètres de haut et qui pourrait
s'écrouler sous leur propre poids s'il
n'avait pas cessé concept de
minimisation des masses et on remarque
que la topologie permet de se rapprocher
de ce genre de structure alors cette
skype dont un petit peu le tournis pour
deux raisons la première est évidente et
la deuxième et qu'elle met quand même en
relation deux secteurs scientifiques qui
était complètement divergents la
biologie et l'ingénierie mécanique cette
technologie favorise les échanges
interdisciplinaires et de la neige
beaucoup de choses le jeu va encore plus
loin puisque en 2014 une équipe de
chercheurs a publié des résultats qui
sont ceux que vous voyez sur votre
gauche et qui sont une étude sur
lesquels se sont amusés à partir du
crâne d'un reptile à mettre en place
tout un système d'optimisation et quand
vous faites la boucle complète vous
retombez sur des résultats par typologie
qui sont donc la figure eux qui
correspondent très fortement à ce que la
nature produirait en figure un d'un
autre exemple d'une pièce produite par
la société thalès qui rappelle très
fortement des structures organiques on
dirait vraiment de l'os enfin je voulais
finir par quelques succès story qui
illustre mon propos une première pièce
qui a été fabriqué par l' agence
spatiale européenne les uns et qui a
pour objet d'assurer la liaison vos
vertus en des panneaux solaires d'un
satellite
vous avez la pièce le modèle précédent
tels que j'ai appelé où le modèle
classique fabriqué par usinage sur votre
droite qui pesait alors je n'ai pas les
poids exact mais j'ai les rapports de
points et vous avez un côté le modèle
démonstrateur donc il yad'autres
poignées noires puisque c'est un
démonstrateur et les gens pouvaient
vérifier que ça marchait bien et vous
avez la pièce au centre et la gauche
telle qu'elle est dans le satellite la
masse a été divisé par cinq
vous voyez je vous parlais de 150 mille
dollars par kilo quand vous divisez une
masse par cinq
l'industrie est preneuse
et vous avez même un coût de revient de
la pièce était divisé par quatre un
énorme succès story à mes yeux l'un des
plus grands enfin deux autres pièces
toujours de lézat la première qui
n'utilisent pas vraiment la topologie
sur votre gauche mais qui utilise aussi
une propriété de formes complexes en
venant insérer des mousses métalliques
des treillis métallique à l'intérieur
des pièces
vous voyez que vous passez de 222 à 164
g uniquement avec ces nouveaux concepts
et ses nouvelles machines
vous pouvez diviser d'environ 20% la
masse est sur la droite une pièce
également de leysin qui sert de porte
antennes et vous êtes passé de 1400 à
940 g là aussi une très forte réduction
de masse enfin pour finir je voudrais
vous dire que la topologie je vous ai
montré effectivement des secteurs
industriels très précis mais au travers
de la fabrication dit yves elle peut
s'attaquer à tous les sujets il suffit
après de mettre un petit peu l'argent
qu'ils sont des technologies qui sont
encore un peu cher et cette image le
prouve en vous montrant c'est une étude
qui a été faite à lienz et grenoble donc
une école d'ingénieurs ou les ingénieurs
sont assez friands de ce genre de cas
d'étude s'agit d'un décapsuleur qui a
été optimisé au travers de ces méthodes
là et produit derrière à l'université
lyon ii et grenoble s'en est suivie bien
sûr tout un tas de test
vous imaginez les étudiants s'en sont
pas privés voilà je voulais finir sur
cette note
et puis j'espère que je vous ai
intéressés avec la topologie
l'impression 3d et la fabrication
additive et que je vais découvrir un
nouveau secteur industriel merci